and now my interview with president
trump
mr president thank you so much for being
here today we really appreciate it thank
you
i know you're heading to pittsburgh
tomorrow and uh rabbi jeffrey meyers
from the tree of life
synagogue said last night the following
i want to address for a moment
some of our political leaders who are
here
ladies and gentlemen it has to start
with you as our leaders
my words are not intended for as
political
fodder stop the words of hate
so given his words what do you think
your role tomorrow will be and should be
well i'm just going to pay my respects
i'm also going to the hospital to see
the officers
and some of the people that were so
badly hurt
so and i really look forward to going i
would have done it even sooner but i
didn't want to disrupt any more than
they already had disruption
but i look forward to going to
pittsburgh tomorrow um you said over the
weekend you might even tone
up your rhetoric the media today seized
on it at sarah huckabee sanders
press briefing uh they're pointing
fingers at you saying look you could do
more you're the leader of the free world
what do you say to that well you know i
did a rally
and i said in fact i was thinking about
canceling it i also did the young
farmers
and it was great doing that and then i
had a rally afterwards and i said you
know you make them too important if you
start canceling
i remember dick grasso wanted to get the
stock exchange opened as soon as
possible he did a great job
and other things once you start doing
that once you cancel so you're doing a
rally
and rallies are meant to be fun
rallies are meant to be everything and i
said tone it down and then you saw the
group saying no don't tone it down don't
tell me that
so we had a great rally in illinois for
some
great people and frankly um
i think that's probably the way it
should be you should go about
your life you can't let these people
disrupt any more than they already have
which is disgraceful what he did
is disgraceful you can't let it happen
as far as what the rabbi said i agree
with him
the word nationalism has taken on for
the left
this connotation of fueling
anti-semitism hate
even violence do you think that
is fair and do you want to further
clarify
what nationalism means to you to me i
don't have to clarify it means i love
the country it means i'm fighting for
the country i look at two things
globalists
and nationalists i'm somebody that wants
to take care of our country because for
many many years you know this better
than anybody
our leaders have been more worried about
the world than they have about the
united states and they leave us in a
mess
whether it's the wars whether it's the
economy whether it's debt
whether it's all of the things that
they've done including putting in the
wrong supreme court justices and we're
we've really put two great ones in no
i'm proud of this country
and i call that nationalism i call it
being a nationalist
and i don't see any other connotation
than that now as soon as you make any
statement nowadays with the
political correctness world they make a
big deal
i'm not a globalist but i want to take
care of the globe but first i have to
take care of our country i want to help
people
around the world but we have to take
care of our country or we won't have
a country including we have to take care
of our country at the border
when you hear people use the phrase
anti-semitism to describe anything
connected to you
you have a jewish daughter you have
grandchildren
who are jewish what's your reaction to
that and i just received an
award from the state of israel from bibi
netanyahu
thanking me because i moved the as you
know the embassy to jerusalem
making jerusalem the capital of israel
and i just did that now how many
presidents said they were going to do it
they never did it
many many presidents i won't go over the
names but i can tell you every one of
them
i can tell you what every one of them
said i
just opened up and we opened it up we
didn't just name it you know it was
going to take years and years to build
and it was going to cost over a billion
dollars i opened up a beautiful building
for four hundred thousand dollars
already opened saved well over a billion
dollars
and it's it's opened after four months
and you were criticized for that too you
were criticized at the time i believe
for being
too pro-palestinian and now you're
criticized on the other side
and in fact this horrible human being
this terrible person that did the
shooting
he was not a donald trump fan because he
said i was too close to israel
so uh that seemed to be his reasoning
so i will tell you i'm going to show you
right after this i'm going to show you
the most beautiful plaque it just came
they must have known you were going to
be doing this interview but it was sent
by bibi netanyahu
thanking me for opening the embassy in
jerusalem which as you know
is like the biggest deal the phrase
enemy of the people
another phrase that's been seized upon
by many in the media
many on cnn but not just cnn there was a
woman who was just on cnn a short while
ago
saying that you have radicalized more
people
than isis that was cnn today well that
must be some kind of a sick woman
when i say the enemy of the people i'm
talking about the fake news and you know
it
better than anybody you have news out
there that are so
fake and i can do the greatest thing
ever north korea
as an example we would have been going
to war normal would have been going to
war with north korea i think president
obama would have gone to war very if he
had an extra year he would be in right
now a war with north korea
he told me it was by far and i'm not
knocking him for this he said it's by
far his biggest problem
look at what we've done and yet when
they talk about north korea they say
what's taking so long you know yeah but
you know they've been going on for 70
some odd years and they say i left i
left singapore
where we had our meeting yeah where we
really had a very good meeting and a
good relationship
like what four months ago they say the
new line is what's taking so long
i see how does it help expand your base
to call them the enemy of the people how
does it help
very america question very fair before
we finish up so we've done a great job
with north korea
then they said we can't get him on
anything because the sanctions are on we
got everything there's no missiles we
got our hostages back
we have the remains coming everything so
now they said
he met the new line is i met don't
listen to this expecting they're going
to be fair today
but think of it they're never going to
be fair think of it i met
okay that's their new line i shouldn't
have met so you know and if you go back
to before i got here
uh it looked like we were going to war a
bad war
with north korea so uh but i was here
with reagan i worked for reagan
they called him stupid dumb slept in the
afternoon incompetent warmonger
and he always kind of he was like he had
steely but he was
he but he didn't have uh social media
yeah
he would have fought back uh he didn't
have social media when they
it's my form of of telling the truth
here's the problem
we have a lot of supporters you know
that better than anybody all you have to
do is look at your ratings okay
but you know it better than anybody
those supporters know that they're lying
i watched meet the press this weekend
everything was so
falsely put putting words in people's
are they trying to hobble you in the
midterms because you're the best closer
for this party that's what the
republicans
are going out of their way and i'm
getting 25 and 30 000 people to these
rallies nobody's ever seen
there has never been any this isn't
bragging there has never been anything
like what's happening i went to illinois
united see a boeing 740 said this
massive hangar packed and they had to
use a second hangar for the overflow
nobody's seen anything
and always look what happened for ted
cruz who's doing great now
we left houston he's now doing great
they don't even talk about that race
and his opponent is not very bomber who
sent them send the letters to the
cnn and democrats was a fan of yours he
obviously
also seems insane completely insane so
what do you say about that you put bomb
in quotes they went crazy over that too
over the weekend because you
used the word bomb would you like to
kind of no
i look he was he was insane a long time
before you look at his medical records
he was insane for a long time
bernie sanders had a fan who shot a very
good friend of ours
steve scalise and other people he was
a total maniac nobody puts his name in
the headline bernie sanders in the
headline with the maniac
in fact nancy pelosi said do not
politicize this back at the time
i was in the headline of the washington
post
my name associated with this crazy
bomber now
trump bomber or something but i was in
the headline when they got him they
didn't say
bomb or found they talked about trump in
the headline
now they didn't do that with bernie
sanders when he had
they didn't do that with the democrats
when other people came out
they didn't do that with president obama
with the church the horrible
situation with the church they didn't do
that they put my name in the headlines
it's when i say enemy of the people i'm
talking about the fake news and it is
fake
for which my people understand one quick
story
so a reporter for the washington post
does a story that a
place that i was doing in arena was
empty and
he shows a picture not a very good crowd
mr trump something to that effect
and then it turned out that he took the
picture five hours
before the people started coming into
the arena
the arena was packed and there were
thousands of people outside
they had to retract it but this is the
kind of dishonesty that we have
[Music]
now for more of my interview with
president trump
can we move to some individual races
florida obviously so important
to 2020 but important period andrew
gillum against ron desantis
uh ron desantis congressman strong
supporter of yours
over the weekend you called andrew
gillum you referenced him being a thief
what did you mean by that well the fbi
offered him tickets at eighteen hundred
dollars a piece
and he took him he took a trip with the
same fbi agent
i guess he was posing as a developer or
something the man
stone cold took this stuff i don't even
think she he should be allowed to
continue on with that he responded today
by calling you weak you're howling
because you're weak that's what he said
i haven't heard that one lately that's
okay good that's a change of pace look
here's a guy that in my opinion is a
stone cold thief
and his city tallahassee
is known as the most corrupt in florida
and one of the most corrupt in the
nation
he's a disaster and how he's even close
to being tied is hard to believe
but florida can't have if florida has a
governor like that
and i know florida better than i know
practically anywhere
florida will become venezuela it will be
a disaster
and you have ron desantis who is a
harvard yale guy
he's had a really terrific you know he's
a very good person
he's going to be a very he's going to be
a very good to a great governor
this other guy is a stone cult in my
opinion he's a thief
how can you have a guy like this and you
just look at his record
also look at the job he's done as the
mayor of tallahassee
he's a total disaster john james of
course
running for senate star beto o'rourke is
down in the polls since you
came in texas but john james is only
eight nine points off
his senate bid he's a army combat
veteran
why do you think he's not getting the
plays he's doing so well that i'm trying
to get to michigan that's how well john
james john james is a star
african-american great guy and you know
how
john james he was one of four or five
people running and i'm watching
television and i see
john james i said who's that guy he's
running in michigan
let me see it again and i said that guy
is great he's a star
now she i don't know she's just a clone
for
all she is is a family vote debbie
stabenow
she's been a disaster from michigan
she's an automatic vote for schumer
john james is a young star
and i said i'm going to back him and i
backed him i did a little research i
backed him
and he's taken off he ends up winning
with you know not a lot of money he ends
up winning the primary and he's doing
really well he's down
seven which sounds like a lot that's
nothing because normally they're down 25
or 30.
obama is kind of following you on the
campaign trail he's he was in
wisconsin wisconsin is going to florida
this week
and he brought up the issue of the
caravan and he said the following
they're trying to convince everybody to
be afraid of a bunch of
impoverished malnourished refugees a
thousand miles away
that that's the that's the thing that
that is the most important thing in this
election not health care not
not uh whether or not
folks are able to retire suddenly it's
this group of folks
we don't even know where they are
they're way down there don't fall for
that kind of fear-mongering
we're scare-mongering people on the
border yeah well he's trying to do the
opposite
uh it's the problem with our country
when you look at that caravan and you
look
largely very you know big percentage of
men
young strong a lot of bad people
a lot of bad people in there people that
are in gangs
we don't want them in this country if
they want to come into the country you
have to apply
like other people we have millions of
people coming in they're applying
they're coming in legally
we have a very strong border i called up
the military this caravan is not they're
wasting their time
they are not coming what's the military
going to be able to do obama obama
i'm sending up the military this is the
military and they're standing there
and one thing that will happen no lethal
force they are captured
we don't let them out what has been
happening and we're not as of
pretty recently we're not letting them
out what happens is they would catch and
release
we're catching we're not releasing so if
they want to come over but we're not
even doing that we're not letting them
into this country
we're not going to let gang members but
what if they're applying for asylum
isn't the law because congress
if they apply for asylum we're going to
hold them until such time as their trial
where
we have the facilities we're going to
put up we're going to build tent cities
we're going to put tents up
all over the place we're not going to
build structures and spend all of this
you know hundreds of millions of dollars
we're going to have tents they're going
to be very nice and they're going to
wait
and if they don't get asylum they get
out and very few people they don't
actually if you want to wait they don't
usually get asylum you know that 80 the
problem is
they release them in and then they have
the trial three years later and nobody
shows up
but we are going to unlike obama and
unlike others we are going to take the
people we're going to put them in and
they're going to wait
and you know what two things happen when
they find out that that happens
you're gonna have far fewer people come
up and also president obama
separated children from parents nobody
talks about this
came along and said he separated no
president obama separated him from the
beginning okay just so we all understand
the new york times is saying the
military mr president um
being called up by you is an election
year
play is this politics or is this real
when you
look at that thousands of people
somebody said you know now on that one
they built it down i'm pretty good at
figuring out how many people thousands
and thousands of people on the bridge
when you looked at that bridge loaded up
with people
that's called an invasion of our country
this has nothing to do with elections
and i've been saying this long before
election i've been saying this before i
ever thought of running for office
we have to have strong borders if we
don't have strong borders we don't have
a country
democrats are worried about the latino
vote suddenly they're worried they're
not going to get the numbers to show up
they should be why you know why because
the latinos the
the hispanic americans have the best
unemployment numbers and employment
numbers in the history of our country
the african-americans have the best
employment and unemployment numbers
in the history of our country asians
best
employment numbers in the history of our
country
women 65 years you know all of these
things women have the best numbers
they've had in 65 years
they should be worried how are you going
to expand
into these traditionally democratic uh
areas
kanye west spent some time here it's
fascinating
how big an effect is west on this push
for african-americans
well a person came into my office who
does poll numbers said i do not believe
how good these poll numbers are with
african americans
and you see what's happened with my poll
numbers but here's what
also happened when we have the best
employment numbers the best
median income numbers for all of these
groups
i mean we have the best numbers we've
ever had and i sometimes jokingly say
it's going to be awfully tough to beat
me in the debate
when i have the best numbers ever
produced so i think they should be
worked they should be worried about
the african americans because they're
going to lose them will you do some
events in the um
inner city i'm doing them yeah i already
have them scheduled um
one thing that i think a lot of us are
very concerned about is
what's happening with the market this
year it's flat for the year down a
little bit
off its record high both the s p and the
dow i know you've complained about the
fed before how much is cheap credit
globally as a part of this problem well
remember this
obama president obama had the worst
recap that we've ever had since the
great depression okay
in terms of coming back but he was
dealing with zero money zero interest
money
we actually created value for money so
the people that have money in the bank
and did it the way you're supposed to do
it they're actually getting interest on
their money now
the fed is being very tight now in one
way you have to say that's very
conservative that's a good thing from
the standpoint of conservative i don't
like it
because it closes it down a little bit
but we're up we were up
almost 50 percent from the time i got
elected almost 50 in fact
more in some instances and now we're
down just a little tiny bit
but we have such a strong when you go
job numbers when you go companies moving
into our country
we have so many companies big ones like
foxconn and like the car companies
they're moving back to michigan
wisconsin pennsylvania
south carolina north carolina florida
they're coming back
and nobody's ever seen this you've never
seen it before they left
and they had no intention we just signed
the deal with mexico and with canada we
did a new deal with korea how about
bolsonaro you talked to him last night
what can we expect he's called the trump
of south america
i'm honored but uh we had a great
conversation
and now the head of brazil yeah i could
see that happening you know
brazil's treated as very tough because
they charge very big tariffs brazil has
been very tough
so we'll be able to straighten that out
but and we have of course
what's happening with china china has
been really hurting
our country economically and you see
we're going to win that one it's going
to happen we're going to win that one
how confident are you
about that they like to make a deal
right now i just say they're not ready
250 billion dollars additional tariffs
of that deal 250 billion dollars and
have 267 billion dollars waiting to go
if we can't make a deal
are you optimistic scale i think that we
will make a great deal with china
and it has to be great because they've
drained our country
we have really helped rebuild china
they've taken them
they've been taking out an average of
500 billion dollars billion
a year for many years not going to
happen anymore who's your dream person
to run against in 2020 you've already
raised 100 million dollars uh
dream dream candidate toronto so far i
like them all
i don't see anybody hillary's not
apparently she's not down too
i like her too i'd be very happy with
hillary i like them all
i don't see anybody that i wouldn't
enjoy running against and you know that
could happen but i don't see it right
now
a couple other questions fox viewers
really want to know declassifying those
documents they were kind of kicked over
to the inspector general
why not declassify it all out we're
getting very close to doing what we have
to do i want to wait till after the
election
why are you and ron rosenstein such good
friends now it seems like everything's
been
settled i do get along but this should
have never there should have never been
a special counsel in my opinion
it's an illegal investigation totally a
lot of people agree with me a lot of
people on your show and on other shows
agree
there was no collusion there was never
any collusion it shouldn't have ever
happened
but with all of that being said i do get
along
and i have made everything available you
know why because i have nothing to do
with russia
hillary was a lousy candidate and i did
a very good
job you're going to do she didn't go she
answers
she didn't go to wisconsin she didn't go
to michigan enough she didn't do what
she had to do to win
and it's just one of those things but we
have nothing to do with russia and i
think you that you probably know that
almost
better than anybody uh the uh written
questions to mueller's
uh answers it's ridiculous that i have
to do anything because we didn't do
anything
but we will probably uh do something
else where we'll respond to some
questions how's melania doing she's
doing fantastically
really good she's doing a great job just
got back from africa
and she saw some things that were very
eye-opening and tremendous poverty
tremendous poverty so we're trying to
help
thank you sir thank you very much thank
you thank you really appreciate it